hey everyone welcome back to the
GameSpot demo stage here at e3 2017
joining Oscar and myself is Andy from
Slightly Mad Studios here to well we're
gonna have a live demo project cars -
hey how's it going very well thank you
how's you III been yeah crazy busy uh
have to be as enthusiastic with at the
next person as the previous person got
some amazing stuff to show you guys yeah
a few truths to set straight out there
oh yeah absolutely
let's get going alright what what truth
do you need to set straight oh well you
know you know we there are a few racing
games out there at the moment
yeah I've seen anything right and the
guys at home a known may not know which
one to get there for weird to tell you
that project cars continues to be the
most authentic racing out there game out
there the most technically advanced
racing out that game out there and also
it's still by far the most successful
and number one racing eSport out there
as well yeah I was going to ask you
about that so it's built in from day one
to support eSports and help sort of
cultivate that community yeah so we
started doing this in 2015 we've had
weekly events ever since and monthly
finals and Red Bull 5g were kind enough
to remove Gran Turismo from the roster
and put us in there instead we've been
to Intel Extreme Masters we've been to
Dreamhack we've had two major series
with Logitech and NVIDIA we've got a
current season three which has got the
seven of the biggest best teams out
there fighting for the championship
we're going to be going to the World
Finals in Gamescom to truly crown one of
those guys the champion and give them a
great big trophy so yeah project cos 2
has got eSports built in from day one
because it's just naturally happened and
we've cultivated it as such what's it
like sort of coming up I mean you
mentioned Gran Turismo they're having
you know these mainstays in racing games
and you guys kind of pardon the pun
overtaking them right there we go that's
right I'll no attitude that's that route
we've been making racing games for a
very long time and over that time we've
been gradually nipping at the heels of
those guys and building up our own
technology building up project cars as a
franchise we remember we made it
alongside the fans so we put in features
and game
modes and stuff that they wanted in the
first game we launched in 2015 we were
the best racing game of 2015 from a
number of credible sources with it
financially and successfully well there
and it started what we hoped would be
the start of a brand new franchise so
here we are and whilst other people may
have rested on their laurels with that
stuff we've continued to innovate in
that in that and as you may remember
from the days of like Pro Evo soccer and
FIFA they were battling it out for
supremacy and now we've got to the stage
where yeah we can wholeheartedly put our
hand on our heart and say that yeah
those guys are now playing catch-up with
us which is a fantastic position to be
in
do you still feel like you can learn
stuff from those other franchises though
or is it do you purely feel like your
head and shoulders above them no I would
be completely arrogant for me to sit
here and say I'll know where the best to
be completely blind to that of course we
play everyone else's games we have our
little spies working out to try and find
out what everyone else is doing
absolutely we're big racing game fans
personally I've been a gamer all my life
so every game that I play every game
that the guys back home are playing in
the studio is going to be influencing
every game we'd make from now on so yeah
of course we're looking at what the
competition doing and making sure that
we continue to innovate and set a brand
new benchmark in a number of areas of
what we are doing in project costume but
also you can learn from yourself as well
right is there anything that from the
first project cars that you look back on
and think oh we could have done this
differently and for the second one now
you've improved on that yeah absolutely
and that's what we what that's what we
did day one so although we made it with
the fans we released the game there are
a number of things like a top-10 list of
things that the fans felt we hadn't
quite gotten to or things that they felt
could be improved upon so we fix that
stuff straight away yeah so things to do
with the force feedback handling on the
wheels stuff to do with the gamepad
handling in the first game we gave you
three different presets which were based
off how you may feel other people's
racing games play and you would choose
the one which is most appropriate to you
but the feedback that we got was that
people just want it to work great out of
the box and quite rightly so
so yeah absolute
we learned from things like that and we
fix that stuff straight away so yes the
project cost too had all that stuff
fixed very early on and then we got to
the brand new gamemodes brand new tracks
buy new cars all that kind of stuff what
would you say has been the biggest the
biggest change the biggest innovation
between project cars 1 & 2 I mean it
goes across the board so brand new cars
brand new tracks that's easy right
that's just even more assets to to play
with when it comes to like rallycross
which you guys are watching right now
that's a game-mode that we wanted to get
to for a very long time it's an awesome
game mode which has both tarmac and dirt
based stuff and yet it's we're very
pleased to be able to say you do not
need to go and buy a separate dirt based
racing game in order to get that fix you
know you can have it straight here in
project cars - as well as sliding
sideways and the Mercedes ice racing
circuit over in the northern Sweden in
Lapland so the ability to do things like
rallycross all kind of comes out of the
fact we've got a brand new physics and
tire physics system which I could go
into in infinite detail but I can see
your eyes are glazing over already but
absolutely the thing about it is is that
the the complexity and accuracy of your
tire physics is almost like the
Colonel's secret recipe
it's if you have about that awesome
stuff there that really dictates how
accurate your game is how authentic it
is how the car feels how the wheel works
as well and we've got a brand new system
for project cars - which goes even above
and beyond what the competition are
doing in that respect I think in a lot
of ways sometimes people don't really
understand how changing things like
physics can be so instrumental in
improving your games I would actually
like to talk about more of more of the
the physics things Eva added I mean like
did you just play the first game and
think we should would do this or should
do this and are the you know the more
powerful consoles that we now have like
the ps4 pro Xbox one X a day enabling
you to do that um they are we can do
even more stuff on those consoles but
absolutely we know that please
PlayStation 4 Xbox one PC all need to be
have complete parity we want you to be
able to play the game in our to our
standards you know
on any single platform whatsoever so it
has to work on every console out there
anyway regardless of whether you have
the Xbox one X or the PlayStation 4 pro
version of it but yeah you know there is
a lot of stuff in there that has been
rewritten brought in from the ground up
stuff that the code team looked at and
we were like we need to rewrite this
from the ground up completely stuff that
was just not possible in the first game
that they've now added in there so yeah
and all that all that stuff makes it
even more authentic even more accurate
even more fun in the case because you
know we're talking about we're saying
words like complexity and things like
that which can maybe be interpreted as
hard and not fun yeah but actually all
this stuff in this particular case of
rallycross the new tire physics actually
mean that you can slide sideways even
better when we couldn't really do that
as much in the first game and that's
especially important in game modes like
this where you're supposed to be going
sideways and right in a straight line
you touched on platforms there we've
seen the Nintendo switch come out in the
past few months and absolutely blow up
you know is that is there any chance for
switch version in the future do you
think either this game or another one in
the future
project cars game in the series I'm not
I'm not going to allow people to get
their hopes up for this kind of stuff
unfortunately yeah we're not looking at
Nintendo's switch currently sure are we
are looking at VR right absolutely you
know we were a launch title for the
oculus rift when that came about we've
been working with oculus for three years
before it even came out right and we
were making sure that the entire game
was completely comfortable experience
and it was as immersive as we possibly
could make it and therefore yes we're
project cars to launches the entire game
can be played in VR with that confident
that it's a really comfortable
experience that you can actually sit
there for hours on end and actually as
we found in project cars one it makes
you a better driver the sense of spatial
awareness means that you can judge
braking distances better when you go
into a corner you're looking at the apex
you're tilting your head in to
counteract
the the camber on the actual road when
somebody overtakes you you can't help
but instinctively glance left or right
you can look in your rear view mirrors
and see who's behind you all that kind
of stuff you know makes the game far
more immersive when our real drivers get
in there and put VR in there they are
treating it like real life something
clicks in their brain and whenever they
go to crash or something they
immediately go into the brace position
because they the sensation of realism it
is absolutely accurate so you find that
people's lap times are quicker when
they're playing in VR then yeah I mean
what we're seeing is that many of our
eSport pros are actually chant moving to
VR because of what I just said it gives
you a tactical and skill advantage over
those who don't so yeah you know the
racing genre has always been pretty
accepting of brand new peripherals
wheels pedals seats all that kind of
stuff and now finally we've got helmet
so yeah absolutely you know VR we when
the game launched we supported so many
steering wheels we actually caused a
international shortage of wheels which
we was an amazing thing we're very sorry
for of course but equally like amazing
but you know that because the wheels of
course the most natural user input
device for a racing game and now we
believe that VR is also like it's a
project cars to especially is a a
pinnacle title for you you said earlier
that it's you I think you said the
number one hardcore simulation game I
think we all words is it hard to try and
balance appealing to that hardcore
audience at the same time as appealing
to people like myself who maybe only
play one racing game a year you know I'm
not a hardcore fan in the genre is that
difficult to try and balance those two
audiences so what we do is that the the
same game that you buy for $60 whether
it's on PC or ps4 or whatever it's still
the same game that the Pro drivers play
on a motion rig in VR training for their
real-life races which is the same one
that you sit down on a Saturday night
with a beer with your feet up you know
just trying to playing a completely
different experience but it's still the
same under
game there it's just as complicated and
authentic and challenging as the one
that the pros are driving but we now
make sure that the user interface the
presentation the way that we present
things to the player whether it's the
defaults that we put in or adding an
additional sliders to make sure the
opponents are set correctly the way that
you can now simply choose you know car
track press Start and off you go as well
as having all the advanced settings in
there if you really want to dive deeper
and project cars one it was a little
overwhelming be a number of sliders and
features and options that we gave you
this time around it's a lot more slickly
presented which is going to allow you to
get into a game a lot quicker and in
things like career mode we're adding in
even more accessibility options by
allowing you to do short seasons post
alongs you don't have to do 12 rounds of
a whole season we've made it even more
streamline to get into a race in the
first place and remove things like the
calendar where previously if you've got
an invitational event you had to wait
all year for it to appear in the
calendar then play it and if you failed
you have that wait another year to do it
now we treat them like rewards and
they're in this awesome bucket that you
can go into and play as many times as
you want so yeah we've really learned
from the first game and also the
feedback that the players at home have
been telling us and we've yet to say
refined and streamline the whole
experience Andy thank you so much drinks
I'm afraid we're out of time but it's
not long to wait until we can play
project costume yeah absolutely
September 22nd on PlayStation 4 with
PlayStation 4 Pro enhancements Xbox one
with Xbox 1x enhancements and steam as
well thank you so much for joining us
guys make sure you don't go anywhere in
a couple of minutes we will have The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
Master Trials live on the stage see them
you